An ambitious idea that spent most of a decade
in a cycle of living and dying might have
reset the clock on itself for the last time.
Here's why the Edge of Tomorrow sequel may
be buried in the rubble of yesterday.
While speaking with MTV News in 2015, Tom
Cruise revealed that he had pitched an idea
for an "Edge of Tomorrow" sequel to director
Doug Liman and co-writer Christopher McQuarrie.
Though the star didn't reveal any details,
Cruise confirmed that Blunt would be interested
in joining the project the following year.
A few months after Cruise's comments, McQuarrie
confirmed to Collider that the creative team
had the idea for the sequel ready to go.
Ideas turned into words as 2016 brought the
news that "Race" writers Joe Shrapnel and
Anna Waterhouse would be penning the sequel,
with Deadline reporting that McQuarrie would
join as producer and script consultant.
By the end of 2016, Liman had signed on as
director and revealed to Collider that the
upcoming sequel would be a prequel.
It's unclear if that was the idea Cruise originally
had pitched.
Liman, however, was completely enthralled
by the idea of returning to the world of "Edge
of Tomorrow," telling IGN,
With such high expectations, one would assume
that cameras would begin rolling as soon as
possible, but Cruise instead went on to focus
on "Mission: Impossible — Fallout," stalling momentum.
As 2018 came around, it was confirmed that
the sequel would be titled "Live Die Repeat
and Repeat," with Liman enthusiastically telling
Collider that he, Blunt, and Cruise were passionate
about the sequel.
He also confirmed that previous scheduling
issues between the trio had been worked out.
While Doug Liman had hopes to film the "Edge
of Tomorrow" sequel after "Chaos Walking,"
the film is still in pre-production.
Will "Live Die Repeat and Repeat" ever come
out?
It seems unlikely.
A few short months after Liman expressed enthusiasm
about Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt returning,
the director revealed that a new script was
being written by Jez Butterworth, who co-wrote
the original film, via Collider.
Later, "The Invention of Lying" writer Matthew
Robinson was courted in 2019 to rewrite the
script, The Hollywood Reporter confirmed.
While the "Live Die Repeat and Repeat" script
was changing hands, Blunt revealed to IndieWire
that Cruise wanted the sequel to film in 2017.
The actress declined as she had already signed
on as the titular character in "Mary Poppins Returns."
Blunt did, however, confirm that was interested
in returning and was hopeful that Liman would
produce a quality script.
And the director did, confirming in 2019 that
the script was ready, putting the ball in
Cruise and Blunt's court, via ComicBookMovie.
In 2021, Liman told Collider that the script
was still being worked on but that it was
in a good state.
Revealing that it didn't matter how far along
the script was, he said,
With Christopher McQuarrie and a wide variety
of other writers working on the project, changing
its vision, it's easy to see why Cruise and
Blunt didn't commit early on in the writing process.
"Can't stand the sight of blood, not so much
as a papercut." [laughing]
Ask Emily Blunt and she'll say that the proposed
sequel has too large a price tag.
Speaking to Howard Stern in 2021, the actress
said she can't imagine how the film would
be made in a post-COVID world.
"Honestly, I think the movie's too expensive."
Following the rising cost of goods and supply
chain issues for key products, Hollywood has
been actively trying to lower production costs,
according to The Hollywood Reporter.
Blunt said,
Warner Bros., the studio behind "Edge of Tomorrow,"
has seen its fair share of difficulties in
recent years, casting doubts on their ability
to bankroll a less-than-sure project.
After AT&T exited the company, the entertainment
giant holds $47.5 billion in net debt, according
to Insider Intelligence, making it crucial
that the next few years feature a string of hits.
Even if Cruise, Blunt, and Liman could align
their schedules, it doesn't look like Warner
Bros. is in the position to pony up the $100
million plus the "Edge of Tomorrow" sequel
would demand.
However, fans of the franchise shouldn't lose
hope, as there's a possibility that a series
could hit HBO Max in the coming years.
"You're not going to believe what I'm about
to tell you."
"No, I'm not."
Warner Bros. made the shocking choice in 2021
to send its entire theatrical slate to its
newly launched streaming HBO Max.
Village Roadshow, a frequent co-financier
of Warner Bros., sued the media giant for
a breach of contract by sending "The Matrix
Resurrections" to HBO Max, according to The Guardian.
Made publicly available in 2022, the court
documents of the lawsuit revealed that "Edge
of Tomorrow," another property that Village
Roadshow had its hands in developing, is on
track to receive the HBO Max treatment.
The contents of the documents don't suggest
what stage of development the "Edge of Tomorrow"
series is in, or if it will feature Tom Cruise
and Emily Blunt.
No creatives, like Doug Liman or Christopher
McQuarrie are publicly attached as of now.
Recent years have seen several successful
films be adapted for television, like "Let
The Right One In" and "Cobra Kai."
So it's not too surprising to see the potential
Warner Bros. sees in adapting the sci-fi action
flick for the small screen.
The series could potentially retell the events
of the original film and implement's Liman's
idea for a sequel for a second season.
Or, it could go in a different direction,
focusing on another military member getting
stuck in a time loop.
Anything is possible, especially if the series
hits HBO Max, which has proven itself as one
of the best streaming services.
As for where the sequel currently stands:
who knows?
Only time will tell if "Edge of Tomorrow"
is destined to get a sequel or if the HBO
Max series will manifest.